let's go next to mark from San Antonio
Texas mark from San Antonio welcome to
the David packman show
Mark please unmute yourself and then
I'll be able to hear you
hey David
um quick question you know I know the uh
the loan forgiveness thing is kind of uh
sketchy right now and up in the air but
really why do you think there's no
appetite from Congress to have any kind
of uh legislation around you know either
capping the amount that tuition can be
raised a year because it's floating or
even you know taxing uh you know these
endowments I mean Harvard alone I think
through their endowment during covid by
13 billion dollars and all of this is
you know essentially tax money you know
the CEO of the Harvard management
company is the highest paid person
associated with the with the school I
mean why do you think there's no
appetite to go legislate that I mean I
can understand the private loan side of
it you know very much in bed with with
Congress but you know you know
universities by and large really can't
donate to any kind of you know uh
political uh affiliation so I don't want
to be defeatist and I know when I give
you the reasons why we aren't seeing
those things people will write to me and
they'll say David if you don't believe
it can be done then of course it won't
happen you're gonna you know depend take
the wind out of the sails now I'm going
to tell you why it hasn't been done for
now and why it's a difficult thing to do
um
putting a limit on how much tuition can
be increased
I I don't see how you could possibly
pass that Republicans would say you're
you're telling institutions how they
need to uh you know price their product
or service which of course is done there
are there are industries that are price
regulated but the opposition to that
would be absolutely off the charts in
order to tax the endowments of these
institutions essentially what you're
talking about is a wealth tax I mean
remember that we already have different
types of taxes for different types of
financial transactions and some have no
tax but to say we're simply going to tax
the Holdings is a sort of wealth tax and
I just don't see any way in hell that
right now you get something like that
passed doesn't mean that these are bad
ideas or we shouldn't try I'm not saying
activists shouldn't be calling for these
things but to answer the question of why
hasn't it happened it's because these
would be
such difficult things to get consensus
for from the current House and Senate of
the United States
right well thank you a quick drummer
question I'm a drummer myself
um you know I know you're a big fan of
Josh Ruiz but as far as a player um you
know who do you try to emulate the most
or stylistically sound like I don't
think I have any particular drummer I'm
trying to emulate I mean I think I you
know study so many different drummers
from so many different genres and time
periods but I couldn't really say
there's any any one uh any one person I
mean you know it's sort of like you're
gonna learn things from like Carter
Beauford from Dave Matthews Band that
are unique to Carter and they're going
to be completely different from the
things that you'll pick up from like a
Steve gadd or uh you know from watching
old Buddy Rich videos or whatever the
case may be so I think it's a sort of
consume everything sort of approach
yeah I mean I started off as a punk rock
drummer took a break from it for a while
when I came back I was like oh I can't
play that fast anymore and so then I
started kind of listening to some you
know like you've mentioned Steve gadd
and Kirk Beaufort and all those guys oh
that's interesting so you after after a
break like you think physically you can
no longer play as fast
correct yeah how old were you when you
took a break and how old were you when
you restarted
oh boy you just cut out I heard 30. what
was that start
I started around 12 years old
um and I played up until I was 18 19 you
know sold my gear went to college and
then uh picked it back up I want to say
27. wow and then you had a diminished
physical capacity
right which is yeah I mean foot speed
was kind of gone and I'm sure if I if I
committed to it and you know really
tried I could get some of those chops
back but then or else it was just like a
complete disinterest in it fair fair all
right well we're going to look into it
strongly
all right okay thanks very much
appreciate the call